joining us right here on the Rich Eisen
show from NBC sports Boston he's our
resident go-to guy he's Tommy Curran how
are you Tom was it a five nine eight I
mean everyone knows you run and we
appreciate that but sometimes I lose
track of a number yes it was 5 9 8
that's at least a half second
improvement from the initial run right I
will tell you this tom
I was timed based on good fortune by
three individuals Jerry Wright Jerry
Rice who was there on behalf of run rich
run by running against a philanthropist
businessman named Mark Laurie and
because Mark beat Jerry Michael Rubin
gave a quarter of a million dollars to
the charity unbelievable - George kid
like George kid allow the goodness of
his heart took some of his time and came
in and then Vaughn an eight-year-old boy
from st. Jude who I think started his
stopwatch the minute I walked up to the
line because his time was more like a
gymnastic score than anything else like
nine five so we took George's time which
may have been very very friendly I don't
know but I'll take it
five nine eight yeah there's no reason
to do what you just did at all I mean we
raised a ton of money Tom a lot of guys
helped but yeah nine eight yes I believe
it I know I know thanks for doing it Tom
I appreciate it hey look what what
happened with Brady and Belichick this
week walk me through your reporting if
you don't mind sir sure they spoke there
seems to be some discrepancy between
myself and Adam Schefter as to which day
that happened but that's less important
than the fact that they did speak and it
wasn't a productive conversation as it
was termed to me bill acted as if tom
was still under contract to the team
which technically he is but this notion
of business as usual and not treating it
any differently is a bad idea what are
you gonna chill with with Brady what do
you mean by that
business as usual like that hey we've
done this for 20 years we're gonna
doing it my way is that the way I'm
trying to read it because again I'm
marrying it was with Adams tweet on the
topic which I'm sure was so it certainly
came after hours and I'm sure it was in
response to and coming from a different
side of the operation so business as
usual if the Patriots are of a mind that
that's a great way to operate right now
mmm-hmm I think they're missing the
point
business as usual after twenty years
when the guy has been irritated about
his contract and looking for a new one
since 2017 and requested his free agent
status last August because he was kind
of fed up if you're going to present
business as usual to him he's gonna walk
out of that meeting or hang up that
phone and say yep well they still really
don't understand where I'm at with this
so what does let me let's let's get
right into this here is Tom piss is Tom
pissed at the Patriots is he pissed is
that I mean that's ongoing education
just ongoing agitation but what's the
agitation about what what is he agitated
about like what would you business or
some question it's funny because someone
said Dale Arnold said on the radio the
other day I still don't understand what
Tom's motivation is here is it money is
it and I said Dale if you don't know
what his motivation is we've done a
terrible job Tom Brady feels as if he's
a stopgap Tom Brady feels as if he's
been trying to be replaced since 2014
when they drafted Garoppolo he beat that
challenge back he wanted a contract that
took him through his stated desire to
play until at least 43 and the Patriots
resisted that they gave him a contract
with incentives he had no shot of
reaching he failed to reach all of them
this past year he was expecting a
two-year twenty five million dollar a
year deal similar to Drew Brees
he can get that and after that he says
you know what I'm not gonna do this
anymore it's too long you've been trying
to replace me you have been screwed
around on the contract I don't have
people to throw to crunket screwing
around with through hoops left and right
to see what would my availability for my
trainer is going to be enough I'd like
to be a free agent at the end of the
year and then we can decide whether we
want to continue the marriage because
clearly you're not convinced that you
want you
the Patriots like yeah let's go here to
here we all agree that's a great idea
no they didn't Brady didn't go
year-to-year he wanted to be guaranteed
that he could stay here that's why we
are where we are that's why there's
agitation in irritation and he knows the
bill is not going to pay him
twenty-seven twenty-eight twenty-nine
million dollars and carry a cap hit
along with it it's not going to happen
it's why the house went on the market
that's why the families moved to New
York that's why he's divested himself of
you know regular on the clock scheduled
Best Buddies involvement this summer
that's why any number of things that
happened that's why it's out there that
he is on the cusp of weaving he's gonna
listen to them he wants to listen to
them he wants to do them that solid
because he believes that's what it's
about I had a quote earlier this year
it's just not who he is he's got an
attachment here and the Patriots want to
keep him around but they're not entering
the for a to keep him around that we so
far and again it's my turf it's not
March 15 but they didn't enter into it
with frothing at the mouth about keeping
him Tom Curren NBC Sports Boston
Patriots insider right here on the Rich
Eisen show let's talk about the Robert
Kraft of it all when does he step in and
and make a pitch make a play make a stop
make a save however you want to put it
great what do you think great question
um Robert Kraft mm-hmm can only go so
far he can't take them together and you
know like a couple of kids you know
getting a squabble on the playground
make him shake hands and be friends if
there is a gap to be bridged
my understanding is I've been told
mm-hmm that Robert Kraft will do that
and I've written that the Patriots will
extend themselves to get it done but if
it's not a gap but a chasm this really
very literally can do so if Tom's
intimations that look I'm looking all
over the place and
that all the informations are accurate
that all these places are interested
which I do know they are correct and the
Patriots that are selling out and Bill's
like look if he wants to go someplace
else Roberts we got to do we got to do
we got to do has gotten us here in terms
of value in terms of understanding what
the economics of it are in terms of this
being a 43 year old now he wants to go
two years we've been here together every
other year does that make sense to you
that Robert Kraft is going to say look I
did everything I could and that's one
interesting thing to rekey pin my
nourish in 2013 they signed him to a
six-year 60 million dollar extension
kind of reasonable at the time and Kraft
told Peter King I wanted to do something
elegant I thought like the fan with this
because I never wanted to see Tom play
someplace else in Roberts mind he feels
he's already done everything he could do
to make sure Tom Brady retired a patriot
he didn't only do that contract he gave
another extension excuse me no he did
not but they've given him the deal the
raise is past year but he feels rightly
that look if this guy's going to play
until 43 he's in uncharted territory and
there's a point at which we have to say
we tried to make it happen this way but
it's gotten to untenable to make it
happen without mortgaging our future
okay Tom Curren here on the Rich Eisen
show let's talk about the possibilities
of where he might land what what what
are Creek Tom's criteria as to where he
might land based on what you understand
Tom a sense of comfort sense of ability
that he's going to win mm-hmm
he's going to be in a situation where
the team is championship competitive and
he likes the place where it is I think
there's probably with sometimes a
disconnect between and I trust
implicitly Jeff Darlington's reporting
on this because he's not only talked to
sides involved the principles he also
noted that he's spoken to eight
executives from different teams about
their interest and levels of interest
but it exists but there's a gap between
the places Tom would like to go and the
way that list looks and the way the team
who would be interested in him shakeout
and I think that's interesting for
instance I mentioned earlier this week
the 49ers I believe that would be Tom
Brady's number one destination they have
so much to work through do you walk the
plank with Jimmy because you feel as if
he's good but he's not great there's
things we could do better he's got a
favorable contract though and if you
bring in Tom Brady at 43 just so that
maybe you can get Kirk Cousins down the
road which is what Kyle Shanahan as we
all understand is always wanted that's a
big gamble meanwhile I don't know if
Jimmy even lands back out here if he's a
free agent and because he's been
released but that's another story so the
miners would be number one then I think
Tennessee even if the Patriots fit in
there somewhere and then you have a
collection of teams who will be
interested in Brady who it would take
some convincing to get him there that
would be the Colts which I'm hearing
exists even though we've been told that
they do not the Raiders the Chargers the
Dolphins in the Bucs
would fall into that next tier of teams
and I think with the Box excuse me with
the with all of these teams with the
Raiders the Colts and certainly the
49ers all of them need to have plausible
deniability in case they didn't get they
don't get Brady that they were never
really interested in the first place
because they have quarterbacks on the
roster right so they can basically say
let's just go as planned here when Tom
chooses somewhere else that's why
everybody's not really declaring their
hand and as you point out where we're
about 10 days from this thing truly
heating up or or maybe maybe even later
than that Tom Caron here on the Rich
Eisen show let's game out the 49ers
thing for a second because you know I
don't think they'd released Jimmy I mean
they'd trade him and obviously teams
would know that he would be on the Block
and they could kind of you know before
pulling the trigger on Brady make that
deal they have the same agent Garoppolo
does have three years of regular
relative affordability
right there in the mid-20s and it
doesn't cost much on the cap 4 and
change to trade him so it is all
feasible the question yes
you know what would the Patriots want
him back would they take him back is
that is that something like Deon when he
was on NFL Network on Sunday and posited
the same thing about the 49ers being the
favorite and the best spot for him to go
doing a basketball sign-and-trade
essentially and reversing the polarity
on the deal that sent so much in motion
leading to this point right so what do
you think reversing the polarity I like
that yeah feel free to use it Tom go for
it sideline for me on this was you know
do you I'm saying that and then Florio
saying that and I texted back and forth
with Mike and he mentions you know the
49ers are real so I was on with Adam
shine and I mentioned Underhill he asked
me where do you think toupee where do
you think Brady ends up I said 50% New
England 50% Tennessee okay there's a
hundred for the hell of it I throw the
Niners coming up hard on the outside I
was half joking after saying that I got
at least a half dozen different people
in the league in the media around it say
do not back off of that
that's real all I can establish though
from myself and not secondhand right
media folk or people within the league
is one that Tom Brady wants to go there
into that it is factual that there are
limitations the Kyle Shanahan believes
or exists in Jimmy Garoppolo this game
does he hate him
no does he think he can win with them
they just did would you entertain the
idea of Brady with John Lynch I don't
know I'm led to believe by people that
that will be the case and so that's
where the Niners come in unbelievable I
mean this is just totally crazy talk so
game it out for me last a few minutes
with Tom Curren here in the Rich Eisen
show time liner for me how does this
great yeah yeah I found it interesting
that in talking to Dana White yesterday
British excuse me that he would be
weaving Thomas I'm gonna do it for clear
you know you're gettin in your 50s when
you starting to do that just wait and
family for this for the audience rich
uh-huh he's got he said he was gonna
leave the area with his family which on
one hand yeah it's 2020 you can do it
remotely on the other doesn't he wanna
sit with people yeah I reported last
month that the chance existed that he
would be stationed in one place and
people would come to Mohammed you know
like the Randy add like Durant out there
in the Hamptons exactly right uh which
Brady was a part of pitching as well
that's right thought that was a good
idea but if he's gonna be out of town
it's gonna be tough to do secondarily
and I haven't really reported this and
because I haven't I'm not blocked on it
I've been told this mmm-hmm probably
it's gonna take a long time this isn't
going to be a a week long process it's
gonna be quick so mmm we'll see how that
goes to me that means he has a smaller
wish list for destinations than the
eight teams you know there might be
teams interested but he might say yeah
that's not realistic for me but the
Patriots at some point the Patriots at
some point I mean Robert Kraft is just
gonna sit around and just watch this go
down and and you know what I mean like
at some point you know the the rumors
are gonna go flying and or weird stuff
that's actually real there's gonna be a
fire we might just be smelling the smoke
and he's gonna step in and basically say
we got to do this you have to do it we
have to do it and then have to figure
out a way just to as you said comfort
level is his number one you when I asked
you what his number one stuff criteria
as you said comfort level whatever
discomfort that might be going on for
him to stay there based on he doesn't
feel heard or he doesn't feel like he
can he's been respected on the life's
that he requires within the building to
use the phrase or or or say so that he
thinks he is earned after 20 years yeah
how do we bridge that how does that get
bridge that's a great question because
you're right
Robert he's not gonna stand there and
say geez I don't know what Bill did I
don't know if he talked to him didn't
talk to him I don't know how these phone
calls went when Tom Brady leaves if he
does leave and goes to free-agency the
optics and I do hate the word optics the
optics will be horrible if the Patriots
can't say we did this this and this we
made a legitimate effort and we leave on
good terms they have to make that happen
so that I think would be the area in
which Robert would step in mmm the idea
of financial step in I don't think it's
going to exist I would imagine it's more
long look Tom mmm we both know how bill
is he's not going to do all the things
that are gonna make you feel warm you
want to hear them again from me of
course I love you and that's where it's
interesting too rich is that Tom Brady's
discontent is not just limited to bill
he understands that over the course of
his career he's negotiated more
contracts with Robert Kraft and he has a
bill belichick so when he looks at this
contract says well I don't have a new
one he's not just looking at bill
looking at Robert he's looking at both
yep and bill is being deferred to by
Robert which is fine he's an employee's
supposed to run the team but that's
that's what the that's that's the best
summation I can give you right now so
Robert stepping in will be a stepping in
to make sure that everything was done
and love was expressed and go fly if you
love somebody set them free will happen
but he will not want it to be
contentious and ugly last one for you
Tom what did you make of Antonia Brown
saying Brady's told him you're coming
with me wherever I go would you make it
that one 100% 100%
curat no Brady might be saying that to
him because he likes him a lot and feels
he was done wrong here in New England
and wants to see him succeed and looks
at what's happened since football was
taken away in to see if you do that to
somebody this is what happens but I
don't think that Brady would hold his
breath and say this has to happen here
but I do know that that Brady is
maintained contact and support with
Antonio Brown throughout so you could
scratch Raiders off the list if that is
his opening dimension Antonio Brown
joining the team well an assurance that
will look at Antonio if he's reinstated
then yeah I would say scratchboard
Raiders Tom you're the best man great
chat we're gonna reach out to you again
this thing's only gonna get hotter
appreciate the time look I didn't need
to but my throat better you know what
lozenge next time if you want blue
syndrome that's part that's gonna be
part of our new merchandising Rich Eisen
show lozenges we'll send you a few
package we got a Haram fat of Tom Curren
ad text I'm on Twitter